what happened in Vegas used to have to
stay in Vegas at least when it came to
betting on sports but that's changed
dramatically in the past few years with
more than 30 States and the District of
Columbia allowing legal betting on games
in person online or both it's projected
to be a 129 billion dollar industry by
2028 and as Brook Silva Braga shows us
betting has become increasingly
intertwined with the games themselves
on a Wednesday afternoon in Pittsburgh a
journeyman catcher stepped to the plate
strike to Tyler heinemann but even this
low-stakes baseball moment had people
betting on what Tyler would do next he's
about four to one to strike out five to
one to hit a single in fanduel's New
Jersey office Trader Tom Heenan tweaked
the odds while his boss will twin looked
on and this is a big part of what we try
and do we want to give a really
Innovative betting experience for our
customers
okay he walked someone had walked
someone did at 13-1 oh that's pretty
good they turned their 100 into 1300 for
a walk
Sports bets used to be placed in Las
Vegas before the game started the odds
or point spreads were never discussed
during the broadcast and don't forget to
play fanduels over under game four now
in-game betting made from a phone what
you need to do is download the BET MGM
Sportsbook app is promoted seemingly
constantly he scored a touchdown in
eight of the last 10 games Mike
raffensberger is fanduel's Chief
marketing officer I personally think
there may be no more disruptive force in
sports than gaming and you must think
that's a good thing I think it's an
excellent thing and by the way we're the
official Sportsbook of the NFL the NBA
the NHL we have a long-standing
partnership with MLB the WTA the PGA the
league think so too it's a remarkable
reversal for the leagues just 10 years
ago they sued New Jersey to stop Sports
gaming here's NFL commissioner Roger
Goodell five years ago we still strongly
oppose of legalized Sports gambling but
in 2018 the Supreme Court ruled New
Jersey and other states could legalize
sports betting I think there were a good
amount of people that were that were
shocked Darren Revell who covers the
industry for the sports Gaming website
the Action Network says leagues that
once insisted betting would compromise
the Integrity of their Sports have
adopted a new position that gambling
supercharges fan engagement it does seem
a little bit insane how you could so
oppose something and then now you're
fully into it why do you think the
switch it's just it's just money hirex
at -124 the money is flowing into
sponsored pre-game segments and in
stadium Billboards and naming rights
it's flowing into commercials I think
Boston's going to cover why you know
something I know and more commercials
you know what to do and more and more
and more commercials these glass is
solid gold the bet is that there's going
to be losers here and that's why you
know this is a good business I need
another tutty out of him for 7.50 it's
not looking too good right now at
fanduel's new facility inside the
Mohegan Sun Casino in Connecticut
even a brick and mortar sports book has
a different feel
pics that win or lose in a matter of
minutes this is going to be a bet on
what's going to happen next first
touchdowns for it all right even with
bedding windows and kiosks right there
many fans still buried in the app they
could use at home Jaguars Morning Line
Trevor over and everywhere parlays these
are bets that have a lot going on in
them yeah that's right bets that require
many picks to all go right 17 Leger no
17 Lexus I mean come on you might as
well buy a lottery ticket Sports books
now heavily promote these exotic bets
you can win a lot of money on a small
bet the long odds benefit the house
fans like how much excitement you can
buy for a few dollars do you do this for
money or do you do
it but they're also quick to bring up
those rare Magic occasions he hit five
during the NBA season win 20 bucks
turned into something like 4 600. what
do you remember about that night I was
sweating pacing around
the next day
in the front row of the sports book we
found Kenny Ackerman self-described
lifelong Gambler from Connecticut who
can final legally bet on Sports in his
home state
this didn't exist like really recently
it's a whole different world
what do you think of that
I think it's bad for society
I like it it's fun
overall access to all these apps and
gambling sites on the Internet is people
get addicted to it and I think they they
gamble too much and it's going to hurt a
lot of people
we know from history the more access
people have to gambling the more problem
gamblers we're going to have why should
people be excited about the expansion of
this thing that we know is going to lead
to bad outcomes for many people so I
challenged maybe the the Assumption in
the question betting was happening
before legal regulated American
companies were running it we really
operate under a principle that this is a
form of entertainment and it should be
fun and have put a ton of effort around
responsible gaming efforts those efforts
include sponsoring a weekly Radio Show
in New York devoted to responsible
gaming my story of personal history with
gambling has been well documented but
that won't outweigh the impact of all
the gambling hype out there now we have
this on FanDuel already you can bet this
according to gambling addiction
counselor Rick Benson and what we are
seeing not surprisingly many of these
young gamblers are as addicted to their
cell phone as they order the gambling
Benson was a problem Gambler himself but
overtime has found it possible to safely
enjoy sports
I still make it a point to stay away
from point spreads those spreads and
money lines are none of my business it's
hard to watch a game now though without
seeing them on the screen do you think
that's a problem for gamblers in
recovery I think it's a problem for
gamblers who are still gamblers and and
some gamblers in recovery absolutely I
think it's a problem but it's unlikely
to change
[Music]
One gaming executive described the
situation to us as a prisoner's dilemma
pushing sportsbooks leagues and
broadcast networks
into ever more aggressive marketing the
touts and everyone else have been
disingenuous about losing have not
talked overtly about bankroll just
because you can live bet something and
it's available doesn't mean you should
do it riskly bet up to one thousand
dollars but ironically it's the cost of
all this promotion that could ultimately
slow it down most sportsbooks are
spending more on marketing than they're
bringing in a gamble that will leave
just a couple big Winners many of the
companies now taking bets just like the
people placing them well eventually be
out of cash
money line for CBS Saturday morning
Brook Silva bracket Uncasville
Connecticut
it's a really interesting dilemma in how
much of this when you look at addiction
and the possibility and this
accessibility and the money that can be
raised for States because there's a
percentage that goes to the states as
well it's fascinating to me how it also
is now with this younger audience my son
at 11 knows about yeah everyone because
you see the ad so much yeah and as long
as if you're doing it with money you can
lose that's the thing and understand
that The House Always Wins right uh but
it can it is an engagement Factor yeah
you know fluorine steroids in the pocket
of your hand we'll see it toothpaste
doesn't go back in the tube